[Music]
a very warm welcome to this edition of
quad riga the international talk show
coming to you from berlin
i'm brian thomas great to have you with
us over the past year there's been a
sharp spike in the number of
state-sponsored killings of journalists
and government critics now although the
details are not yet in nor are they
completely confirmed it appears that the
most recent victim is the late
Washington Post columnist Jamal Kikuchi
an influential critic of Saudi ruler
Mohammed bin Salman now there is
mounting evidence that after entering
the Saudi consulate in Istanbul Turkey
he was rendered unconscious and then
dismembered by a special team sent from
Riyadh that included a number of bin
Salman's personal bodyguards US
President Trump says it is too early to
draw any conclusions but the White House
has requested Turkey deliver the audio
and video it says it has on the last
moments of cachaca she's life chrishelle
cheap and disappeared death by decree
that's our topic today we're focusing on
that with Rick know akiza foreign
affairs reporter for The Washington Post
for which Michelle she also worked as a
commentator recovers Europe and
international security issues and says
politically motivated kidnappings or
killings indicate a new level of foreign
policy assertiveness especially as the
West lacks leadership in defending human
rights and Daniel Dylan boomer is an
editor for the German daily newspaper
tea belt his fields of interest are
Turkey in the Middle East and he says in
a polarized world particularly
journalists become targets because they
act in between political forces and
Nigel Abdul Haq is a freelance
journalist covering in Mideast politics
for DW and for arta she says we are
witnessing a new era of right welcome to
all of you great to have you here on
quadriga let's start off with the
evidence we're depending on Turkey for
the evidence if we could start with you
what do you think Daniel Dylan is that a
dependable source for us to be relying
on absolutely not
it's not a dependable source because we
know that Turkey has general interests
in that turkey is on a geostrategic
level full of Saudi Arabia Turkey itself
has a very bad record in treating
journalists a correspondent of my own
newspaper divas has been imprisoned in
Turkey for more than a year and we also
know that the kind of evidence that
journalists are being provided with is
very bad all those tapes all those
videos that the Turks are leaking not
officially releasing they never give
away the raw material they only give dr.
tapes so we know what they want us to
believe but we don't know what really
happened okay we don't know what really
happened
not what do you think is our we're
talking about one newspaper from Turkey
in particular very close to the
government close intelligence sources do
you think we can count on them as a
source for us to to be moving forward
with this case I think at this we
shouldn't question the the sauce we
shouldn't take all information for
granted one of the basics of
journalistic work is to have a double
check for the information in this case I
know it's very difficult but until now
we don't have any official investigation
on the official statement whether from
the Turkish side nor from the Saudi side
nor know about this joint investigation
team that they announced they wanted to
start it seems they wanted to and then
there is still discussion on that so in
this context I should say we should be
cautious about all details that are
leaked because also the leakage started
from day one and it was let me say a
kind of systemic leaking the
systemically and we're talking about the
the periodical the newspapers sabah very
close to the intelligence agencies they
have been piecemeal leaking out this
information that it comes from a
Hollywood horror film doesn't it
somewhere between Stephen King and in a
splatter film we're talking about bone
saws what do you make of all this well
what I am seeing is that this kind of
choreography of details is actually
catering very well for Turkish to
strategic interest because by revealing
new gruesome details that
get ever more gruesome day by day they
have created a media interest in the
West and in the Western public that has
pushed Western governments including the
one of the United States towards Turkey
and if you look at American Turkish
relations before the start of this
affair and now you will see that Turkey
has become that America has become so
much more friendly to the Turks and I
think that's one of the results of a
very very shrewd public diplomacy using
the media Rick Novick from the
Washington Post keshavjee wrote for the
periodical you work for his last column
was delivered shortly after he entered
the embassy can you tell something about
that sure it was actually delivered to
the Washington Post a day after his
disappearance through his translator and
assistant it was published it wasn't
published for for about two weeks
because we hoped that he would reappear
and has now been published in today's
edition it lays out the state of the
freedom of the press in the Middle East
very dire state and and his hopes that
this might change when for instance by
the creation of a of an independent on
transnational news organization in the
region that offers space and well space
to critics and independent voices Naja
you've just returned from Saudi Arabia
been there from 2016 2017 2018 have you
seen a change has the press there have
journalists come under more pressure
over the years that you've been in Saudi
Arabia reporting what I can say from my
experiences there that there was a
change between 2016 late 2016 2017 as
interna as a foreign journalist I can't
I can't really express anything about
local journalists but as as a foreign
journalist and the team that was working
with me was at art and then later GW it
was clear that in 2017 the whole process
was much faster much easier and
accessibility we had and the freedom to
move on the street was huger than before
in 2016 we were really like as if
shadowed the whole time we knew that
they
people from the ministry we're with us
and they inform informed us about it but
we were really we had to be cautious
with whom we talk and when and the other
visits were much easier there was a huge
cooperation from the Saudi Minister of
Information for our work so I think this
was also because they were interested to
reflect another image of this closed
place or of this closed country that's
what I'd like to discuss how do we
explain this dichotomy that on the one
hand we've seen Saudi opening
liberalizing women allowed to drive DW
reported on that for example and at the
same time this crackdown in this
apparent murder of a regime critic yeah
how is that Exel
well you could only give an exact reply
to that if you knew what's really behind
this affair and we don't but what I'm
seeing in general and how it links to
this special situation is that this
country and this leadership is really
honestly trying to open up this country
but the people who are doing this are
very unused to this kind of situation
they don't know how to handle this and
at least in some instances things go
wrong so this version which we heard the
day before yesterday from CNN which said
that there would be an announcement of a
Saudi narrative that more or less said
that something went wrong in the
treatment of Hokkien that originally
hadn't been planned to be assassinated I
think that's a version I wouldn't
totally rule out because as I said the
people involved are new to this job even
if they're old and older than the crown
prince so age is not the the thing new
to this job of opening up exactly and
being more liberal in their approaches
to interview information for exactly and
conducting a transparent foreign policy
okay Rick what what do you think what do
you think the narrative is coming out of
Saudi Arabia or are we missing one right
now well I mean a narrative that's been
apparently provided to President Trump
is that those were rogue it might have
been broke and
stakeholders who who went there without
the approval of the Saudi leadership
that's at least a narrative that is
being perpetuated and circulated in in
Washington and that is taken by the
Trump government we'll talk about that
exactly and and that brings us to the
question and to what extent is the lack
of American leadership and this kind of
power vacuum when it comes to human
rights when it comes to human rights
criticism or support support in Canada
when Canada opposed
Saudi Arabia back in in the summer to
what extent is this embolden the savior
of to Saudi regime and to what extent
could it have emboldened other countries
worldwide
embolden the Saudi regime nausea could
this have been possible without the
personal orders of Mohammed bin Salman
again here we are in speculations nobody
can assure this I mean investigations of
the Washington Post and that was
required at least his knowledge
I assume yes because because still even
if we have these reforms in the country
it's important icing from my perspective
to differentially between social
economic reforms on one side and
political reforms the country was in
need and is the need for all reforms and
then Hamad bin Salman is interested in
social reforms and in economic reforms
because of economic diversity to create
a new post oil era in the country and it
was time that women become a part of the
social system and of the working system
and of the labor system but still it's a
monarchy and a huge political reform
might question this let's say monitor is
tucumán it's a monarchy it's a monarchy
dad Daniel Dylan I want to jump in here
it's a monarchy that depends on the
Wahhabist religious leadership can you
have a reform of this radical
conservative form of Islam Wahhabism as
you attempt to move the society forward
is Wahhabism capable of reform oh that's
the experiment we are just seeing I mean
what they are trying
is to create a society that is that has
a conservative core but that is still
open for business with the rest of the
world and I think we have been seeing
other Muslim countries starting on that
path and actually I would say the first
results are encouraging and at least in
in the last years we haven't seen as
vocal resistance from conservative Lema
as some people had expected when those
reforms started but the fact that it's
monarchy also plays into this year
because the question of if this is
linked to Muhammad's lamang also depends
on those contradictions you have within
the house of so there are different
camps and this family and those
different so some top family members
arrested they were imprisoned in the
Hilton apparently there there were
accounts of torture as well within the
Saud family which is of course a huge
families and some of those people who
have been deposed in the in the in that
purge are actually focal to the interior
security apparatus so I would think that
the idea that there could be a different
camp opposing Mohammed bin Salman within
the security operators that's a
possibility I wouldn't totally rule out
Rick when when you consider that based
on the information we're using we're
moving forward with right now that
members of bin psalmist personal
bodyguards were among this special team
that went to Istanbul a forensic
scientist also known to bin Salman with
that in mind doesn't that weaken the
argument we're hearing not only from
Riyadh but from Washington that includes
plausible deniability this may or may
not have happened sure it's going to be
very tough for the Trump administration
to continue to back the crown prince if
those details are confirmed but the
question is are they ever going to be
confirmed and by whom are they going to
be confirmed what are the Saudis going
to argue and and do they have any they
haven't been saying that much yet do
they have anything else they can they
can counter those those terms
or ways they can counter it was Turkish
arguments um so I think that the
Americans are the Trump administration
is hoping that it will be able to
continue to back to Saudis and there
have been signs that they are doing that
at the moment I mean the Pompeo visit
the same day one hundred million dollars
were transferred to the u.s. that had
been promised back in a summer I mean
there are signs that the Americans are
trying to move on and overcome this
crisis
regardless perhaps of what will emerge
later on in this investigation and the
question is to what extent you can call
it an investigation of there's so little
there's a little details coming out and
terms of evidence that we're having yeah
so when it's so hard to decide which
which side you're gonna believe and
evidence you know might have been
destroyed when cleaning crews are coming
in hours absolutely there's there could
be some DNA and that cleaning crew
material though we can't forget that we
need to talk a little bit more about
Kishori the man his sources and ties
penetrated deep within the Saudi power
structure both he and but he was also in
contact rather with individuals and
organizations fiercely opposed to the
powerful sound I know ste and bent on
ending its decades-long rule let's look
more at Karachi Jamal khashoggi comes
from one of Saudi Arabia's wealthiest
families he's well-connected with the
Saudi royal family whom he's often
provoked with editorials and articles
critical of the government
during the 1990s he had contact with a
summer bin-laden
he interviewed him before and even after
bin Laden became head of al-qaeda like
khashoggi bin Laden came from one of
Saudi Arabia's most influential families
as a student Khashoggi sympathized with
the Muslim Brotherhood which was
suppressed by the Saudi royal house but
he never saw himself in opposition to
the monarchy he even supported its
efforts at reform could his knowledge
about corruption or old connections with
extremists have made him a target for a
hit squad
Rick Novack from the Washington Post
what made tkachuk she so dangerous what
kishan she was of course a very
prominent Saudi journalist but he also
after his self-imposed exile he
continued writing for The Washington
Post and Washington Post is published in
the capital of the probably most
important ally to Saudis have when it
comes to military supports economy and
so on so he was embarrassing be a Saudi
elite the Saudi leadership in the
capital of one of the countries day
camera most about in the world and I
think that made him especially dangerous
to the Saudis nah jackets it's not just
to shock she senses 2014 at least three
other Saudi critics have disappeared why
is this case getting so much attention
and I think that she became so important
or so dangerous not only because he was
a journalist for The Washington Post but
because all of his history he is really
one of these men who were very close and
not not in the last few years we can say
in the last two decades at least if not
more very close to the to the leadership
and he was very close to abundant in
Sultan and others who I mean even very
close to the Saudi security services so
I think that that's why he's he's really
important or he became dangerous this
case is there it's very special because
he's much more prominent and because the
the situation around that he was in
Washington and and and went to Istanbul
and Wystan Buland I mean people could
follow what what was going on in the
other two cases we knew about it after
it happened there was no follow-up and
there were no news that song is leaving
from one place to another and I think
the whole investigations are and even
the leaks that came or the leaks that
came from the Turkish authorities give
it a push besides this we we have to be
aware that on one side Saudi Arabia owns
nearly all important media outlets in
the Arab world per se Larrabee
Hayate and other newspapers and it's all
set and it supposedly jazeera which is
in we can't forget the lobbying assets
they have in washington and european
capitals as well i just mentioned then
the counterpart is al Jazeera Al Jazeera
which is about to lose its position its
media position in the Arab world was
really a very important media medium
let's say event that they were really
reporting every ten minutes of breaking
news and in u.s. oh yeah all this made
you know yeah this Daniel Dolan is this
it is this is it the media prominence
and the contacts inside the Saud family
that made him such a threat
it's both both of those another factor
that might be relevant apart from from
those two factors is that he seems to
have had sympathies for the Muslim
Brotherhood which the Saudis have
designated a regional for a regional
enemy and they expect everybody to be on
their side and that but I suppose even
more dangerous than that is really his
his knowledge of what's going on inside
the royal family having been so close to
Turk meanwhile the the a longtime
intelligence chief of Saudi Arabia who
stepped down just days before 9/11 he
must have known a lot of what's going on
inside the royal household a possible
scapegoat as well
possible but India on the other hand if
they had wanted to set an example with
his treatment then the Saudis would have
done it differently they would have
brought him to Saudi Arabia they could
have done a show trial they could have
given all this their own style of drama
their own suspense and that's not what
happened I think there's an important
went wrong is somewhere on it went wrong
and exactly how the Trump administration
is going to react to this case is still
not clear the president has firmly
backed the Saudi family and has pointed
to a huge arms deal as an example of the
country's close ties
well there are many other things we can
do but when we take away a hundred and
ten million dollars of purchases from
our country that hurts our workers that
hurts our factories that hurts all of
our companies you know you're talking
about five hundred thousand jobs so we
do that we're really hurting our country
a lot more than we're hurting Saudi
Arabia so is 110 billion dollars the
price of looking the other way and
sacrificing the values that America says
it stands for it's a good question I
think we will see in the coming days
when the Saudis finally put out their
own narrative how America behaves to
that but at the moment we are seeing
Donald Trump I think caring first and
foremost for his own interests that
includes his election interest in
midterms on November 6 and not for
American values Rick this place is the
West not only United States a real
predicament can the United States can
the West condemn and sanction powerful
states like Russia like China and ignore
what's happening or apparently has
happened at the direction of the Saud
family well of course the EU's
leadership has a credibility issue and
it has has had a credibility issue
before that credibility issue has become
a lot bigger now it does appear as if
the Trump administration is trying to
move on that would send I think a
catastrophic signal if there wasn't any
sort of sanction if the Saudis were to
be found responsible and because this
has been on front pages for weeks now I
don't remember another issue
international issue that was on the
front pages for for such a long time
this embodies a lot for for a lot of
people and and I think it would also
send a signal not only to the Saudis but
to also other countries that they can if
you have enough business interests with
the Americans and if you know you can
make a credible argument that you're
important enough that you can
essentially do anything okay important
enough are the Saudis in the driver's
seat right now they control a lot of oil
they could potentially
damaged the US economy by jacking up the
price of oil coming from their wells oh
yeah
yeah but the price of all is not only
related to Saudi Arabia we have other
provider and we have speculations in the
market Iran's not a provider for the
United States right now Iran is now but
it was very problematic as well and the
the interview madman Salman gave to
Bloomberg on October 2nd I think on
October 1st it was a discussion and
there was a discussion of privatization
of Aramco that of American oil company
so they are in the driver seat but we
shouldn't also forget that Saudi is
interested to diverse its economy so
they are also on on the other side that
they need Europe and they need the u.s.
to get away from this only or Seoul oil
economy so it's it's the religion is
much more complex that that only is
Saudi is sitting in the in the driver's
seat this is at least how I see it
because they are interested to have
other elements in their economy and
that's why we have this summit I think
after tomorrow all right noise in the
desert work everyone's leaving
Lugosi means a set foresee many
companies is just about everyone okay
did the United States cross a line when
it started arresting and incarcerating
alleged Islamists in Guantanamo in terms
of being able to press the case for
human rights right now with Saudi Arabia
for example I actually don't think so I
actually think that if anything is true
about the connection between Guantanamo
and what's happening now I think it does
actually in a way also raise the
pressure on Arab governments to treat
dissidents fairer because human rights
in that way has also become a topic in
the Arab world and in Arab societies and
I think that there is more discourse
there I think the topic on how treating
dissident that's a global affair okay
it's a global affair happen how should
it be approached no job I just let us a
global affair we have in fact a question
why it's become a global effort in the
last few years we can take Russia UK we
can take not at all affair yeah and we
in Egypt and the Hungarian journalist
few days ago and I think the that's why
we are in a new phase at least for
journalists in a new era of fear because
five years ago not just would have been
so much worried if he's doing
investigative investigative report or
doing some critical reporting as today
so maybe this is related to the global
situation of moving more to two less
individual rights and human rights and
and going through the process of being
more right-wing if it was Europe or or
the States I mean there is a change in
the general atmosphere and the situation
the other world was always difficult and
it's not becoming easier after that
spring Naja Abdul Haq thank you very
much for being with us today
Rick Nowak and Daniel Dylan boomer as
well thanks so much to all of you for a
great session today and thank you for
joining us here at quadriga
until next time i'm brian thomas thanks
for being with us
[Music]